kremlin spokesperson dmitry peskov says
russia has handed ukraine a written list
of its demands as part of peace talks
keskov told reporters that moscow is
waiting for a response from kiev
russia's earlier negotiation demands
have included ukraine becoming a neutral
country seeding the donesk and luhansk
regions to pro-russia separatists and
recognizing the 2014 annexation of
crimea ukrainian president zielinski
says he has not seen or heard about
this document
and this week zielinski also said that
giving away any territory is out of the
question for
ukraine now let's bring in thomas graham
now he's a distinguished fellow at the
council on foreign relations he joins us
from new york city mr graham it's good
to have you on the program with us
russia says that it handed over its
proposals to ukraine on a path to peace
obviously we don't know
what's inside but
what can we read into the fact that this
path still seems to be open
well i don't think it's a serious path
at this point
in the previous negotiations the demands
that russia were russia was making on
the ukrainians were basically that it
capitulate uh that it agreed to
the independence of the the separatist
regions to russia's annexation of crimea
and that ukraine become neutral uh
clearly all these things together aren't
acceptable to ukraine i don't think that
moscow is engaged in serious
negotiations at this point
so what do you think they're up to right
now
well i think part of this is that they
uh want to to put pressure on ukraine
obviously they are launching a
a new offensive in the east uh they hope
to take over the full old glass of
donatska muhansk
in the near future something that would
allow them to claim
something of a minor victory after the
humiliating withdrawal from around kiev
uh earlier uh in uh in in this month um
and they want to indicate to the
ukrainians that there's still perhaps a
police plan that's open in an effort to
demoralize the ukrainian population and
all this comes on top of the the very
heavy bombardment of ukraine in the past
few days continuing attacks on civilian
infrastructure and civilians so i think
this is all part of a plan to try to
break the the will of the ukrainian
people
last weekend
mr peskov said that president putin is
hoping for an end to this entire
operation within a matter of days
now that got our attention a matter of
days
is russia
maybe
here seeking a way out a chance to be
able to declare
victory by may 9th
well i i'm sure that and that president
putin would like to have something
positive to say by may 9th this is a big
event
in russia the victory over nazi germany
uh but
it's hard to see what he could
accomplish in the next couple of weeks
um
ukraine is being supplied very rapidly
by by western countries they have the
will to fight
they have been quite effective in in
dealing with the russian military so far
so i think the russians are facing a
tough slog uh in the east uh and i would
doubt that putin will have a major
victory to report on may 9th you are
aware that the west particularly the us
and the uk they have
um delivered more and more heavy weapons
to ukraine they are committed to that
um there's also reporting that the
weapons being delivered
um continue to become even more
potent
how worried should we be or is there a
danger of some sort of mission creep
taking place here
well i don't think it's so much mission
creep on on the western side at this
point
but it does create a paradoxical
situation that is that the worse the
russians do militarily uh in the east by
the greater the temptation on the
russian part to escalate the conflict
uh so far the russians have not targeted
uh with any great um
vigor the the convoys that are furring
these weapons into you into ukraine as
ukraine receives much more effective
weapons weapons that it can use to
repulse this
latest
russian
russian
attack i think russia will be tempted to
go after that that does raise the
question of where they would attack
these convoys on ukrainian territory or
where at transshipment points that are
located in
nato countries uh if it's the latter
then that raises the question of article
5 guarantees and could lead to a much
larger conflict
and just briefly do you think that the
chances are very good that we'll see an
attack by russian forces on those
convoys within ukraine
i think the the the risk of that is
growing uh particularly as the
as the military conflict becomes much
more bitter in the east so i would
expect something like this to happen
within the next few weeks
mr thomas graham with the council on
foreign relations mr graham as always we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
you're welcome